foreign
Devonte is with us in Minneapolis if I
can push the button there is hey Devante
how are you
hey how you doing I'm doing well good
how can I help
um well the better interest is just
getting the question out there uh I
guess I'll just say a question you guys
can rip into me after that uh the
question I have is that I have a car or
I have about fifty thousand dollars in
debt the car is a little over half of
that at about 27
um 19 interest rate I'm trying to get
out and then a follow-up question is
just if I'm gazelle intense enough uh
based on how much I'm working and and
the thing they're doing to me you owe 27
000 on a car at 19 percent
yeah yes okay what's the car worth
uh fourteen thousand
uh
uh did you roll negative equity from
another deal into this one
uh no I didn't um okay you're looking at
the wrong number then because a 19 loan
is a subprime loan translation they
screwed you okay or you screwed Yourself
by signing up for this and they have a
different calculation on those loans
when you ask for the balance they use a
total of all payments a top number
to give you the loan balance that is not
the payoff
so your payoff is unlikely to be 27 not
with a fourteen thousand dollar value
how long ago did you buy the car
uh this is about a year ago just under
yeah what'd you pay for the car
uh thus far I've paid about 700. no no
honey what was the price of the car when
you signed the paperwork the total price
of the car not the financing what was
the price of the car
oh I guess I don't know the answer to
that it was 27 on the the only
uh overall price that came out was 27 so
I thought that was the the value
well I mean it's a car's worth 14 honey
you surely didn't pay 27.40 a year ago
unless you went to one of those it was a
third party it was a third-party dealer
um I was just desperate trying to get
into something a little credit
even those guys don't do that
okay so I really think that you probably
actually paid 17 or 18 for the car and
your total of payments is 27. so you
have a a finance company you're paying
this money to right
yes okay call them and ask them for what
the payoff is if I bring a check today
and pay it off
and they're going to tell you more like
20. okay or 18 or something like that
that's the number you're going to get
um
and uh and you obviously don't have any
money right
uh no I've I've since recovered my
situation so I do how much do you have
I'm sorry no uh currently speaking no I
don't have a and savings oh you don't
have any money okay so I was right all
right what do you make
um 100 and anywhere between 113 130
depending on how long have you been
doing that
um four months why don't you have any
money
I've been putting everything to debt
okay all right I want you to stop
putting it to debt because I want this
car to get sold
okay I want you to stop putting it to
debt I want you to save up enough to
sell the car for 14 and put 7000 with it
and sell the car because it's going to
be 20 21 18 something like that payoff
then I want you to go get a two thousand
dollar car and pay cash for it
this car needs to go bye-bye it's bad
juju bad car
there's going to be a sense dude that
you're taking 7 000 or 10 000 whatever
that final payoff is and putting it in
your backyard and just lighting it on
fire and you are and you know you
already did that now all we're doing is
admitting it yeah we're just yeah and
it's gonna hurt and uh it's it's gonna
be a good SCAR or tattoo for you to
never do this again ever yeah and so
yeah desperation makes us do crazy
things man everything you did when you
went on the car lot a hundred percent of
your moves were wrong
you went on the car lot wrong move you
bought a car you never looked at what
it's valued at you have no idea what it
was you just said if I sign here I can
drive it off yes and you signed whatever
they put in front of you you never
looked at it this is the recipe for
getting screwed and if you do it again
you're gonna screw it again if you do it
again you're gonna get screwed again
yeah this is how it works this is how
these people exist in these rip-off car
situations uh and so they feed on the
desperation and the immaturity of people
and so uh the next time this comes up
you need to step back breathe a little
bit and think okay where can I get a
thousand dollar car and like how where
can I get a thousand dollars and let's
get a uh a garage sale car car you
bought a garage sale and drive it around
a little bit and if it goes bad after a
month or two it was still cheaper than
your payments
and go get you another one I mean these
are disposable cars like disposable
phones when you're doing a thousand
dollar car compared to what you're
driving but yeah this thing is uh it's a
weight around your neck it's uh shaming
to you every time you get in it every
time you write the check it's a rip-off
there's nothing good coming out of it I
would do everything I could to get rid
of it as soon as possible